but they really are just carrying water
for the bad policies of the
administration here's a cnn reporter
telling us how excited we all are to pay
a little bit more right now here at home
at the pump a lot higher kate but as you
mentioned people we've spoken to over
the last couple weeks they're okay
paying higher prices if it means holding
russia accountable for what they are
doing in ukraine but these prices are
likely going to creep higher kate we'll
see how they feel in the next week or so
kate and the big question the big
unknown is do any of these moves change
putin's behavior change the way he is
acting right now
these people are fiction writers people
we've talked to are very happy about
paying more if it stops putin it'll stop
putin if we pay a little bit more we've
been talking to people i talk to people
all day long okay are you happier oh he
got a tesla good for this guy you
happier no you didn't even get a car yet
he's working on getting a car you you
got a car you're not happy not he he has
a truck he gave me a sad face people are
not happy about paying more gas and
guess what you paying 73 cents more for
your gas or what will eventually be a
dollar 25 more a gallon or whatever else
is not going to stop putin okay it's not
going to stop putin but at least but you
know look we've got bad news people fine
at least we have these late night
comedians who help us at the end of the
day you know it's because it's stressful
the gas prices going up the supply chain
collapsing food prices going up all the
bad stuff that's happening all over the
world but thankfully we have late night
comedians great people who cross the
partisan divide and you can put on their
comedy programs at night and feel good
because they care about you
here's stephen colbert russia has been
hit with a series of crippling sanctions
and looks like there's more to come
because the us and its european allies
are now discussing banning imports of
russian oil take that putin we're not
gonna buy our gas from a war criminal
we're gonna buy it from the good guys
saudi arabia
but
it's gonna cost
since the invasion oil prices have
skyrocketed today the average gas price
in america hit an all-time record high
of over four dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience
is worth a buck or two
i'm willing to pay
it's important right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon he'll i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla
right now ah nothing like an elitist
millionaire making fun of people who
actually are affected when they have to
pay more uh you look
i i do pretty well i do all right uh i
have a tesla or i'm i'm getting a new
tesla supposedly it's coming this week
um i love the tesla so i'm not i'm not
against green energy obviously i'm not
against electric i'm certainly for
nuclear all of these things but this
smug dismissal of of the average person
who has to drive to work and a couple
bucks a day actually does mean something
these people are just absolutely gross
and ah but you'll have a clean
conscience and all the seals applaud oh
we have a clean conscience now uh guys
we've known putin's a bad dude for quite
some time so did you have a clean
conscience two weeks ago when we were
buying oil from him is your conscience
clean then and he even made the point
you actually almost did it you almost
made like a clear point there colbert
yes we're gonna now buy oil from saudi
arabia more oil from saudi arabia and
maybe go to venezuela et cetera et
cetera so will your conscience be clean
then
god these people are ridiculous